c'est l'un des plus grands événements
populaires de france chaque année
nîmes voit déambuler près de 1 million
de personnes dans ses rues deux fois par
an depuis 1952 la ville vit au rythme
des férias cacit à bodega corrida un
petit air de séville souffle sur ces
pavés pentecôte au printemps et
vendanges fin septembre deux pics de
fréquentation deux événements
indispensable pour les commerçants et
pour l'économie de la ville
alors à qui profite ces fêtes
comment s'organisent ces festivités
populaires comment assurer la sécurité
et quelle place pour la corrida
immersion au coeur de la feria de nîmes
jeudi après midi les badauds commencent
à affluer pour ouvrir les festivités 900
figurants d'associations nîmoise
défilent dans la pégoulade un cortège
très prisé des milliers de personnes
sont venues admirer les chars
c'est un beau challenge c'est un beau
travail on travaille qu'avec des
associations amateurs qui qui qui sont
super il ya une énergie
il ya l'engagement qui était vraiment
qui est vraiment géniale pour sécuriser
les trois kilomètres de boulevard près
de 250 personnes dont une cinquantaine
de policiers municipaux la pégoulade une
véritable institution créée avec la
feria il ya plus de 60 ans et comme le
veut l'usagé
c'est le crocodile qui ferme la marche
l'emblème de la ville le cortège c'est
un près des bars de la maison carrée qui
accueille déjà les premiers fêtards
ce vendredi midi au carré d'art c'est le
début du service au ciel de nîmes
restaurant très couru des amateurs de
corridas jérémie 30 ans et le gérant de
l'établissement
il attend beaucoup de ces quelques jours
c'est les férias qui ouvre nos saisons
on commence à ne fait rien au final
inférieur c'est ce qui encadrent
vraiment entre 16 ans les hivers sont
encore difficiles parce qu'il connaît
comme une ville touristique et la feria
nous permet d'enlever le couteau sous la
gorge pour assurer aussi l'aspect
financier n'est au mieux nos banques et
tout le monde ne fait rien pour nous
auprès sur trois quatre jours peuvent
représenter un mois d'hiver entier donc
c'est assez important avec ses 150 mille
habitants nîmes et aux portes de la
camargue est une ville au tissu
économique morcelé frappée par la
désindustrialisation
ici le taux de chômage est de 13% bien
supérieur à la moyenne nationale
les feria de pentecôte et des vendanges
draine des centaines de milliers de
touristes chaque année et ce tourisme à
nîmes en a vraiment besoin
le feria comme celle ci ça dira pas le
coq qui as un jour de feria sarah pense
surtout bien sûr aux commerces de
proximités essentiellement les bars les
restaurants à l'hôtel rire tous qui
accueillit le tourisme c'est à peu près
environ 20 millions d'euros de retombées
économiques directes ou indirectes
on a remarqué par exemple que beaucoup
beaucoup d'heures de magasins beaucoup
d'artisans bouchers boulangers x 10'
chiffre d'affaires pour la feria parce
que la feria c'est aussi recevoir sa
famille recevoir ses amis dans sa maison
donc forcément il ya beaucoup de monde
qui sont accueillis sur nîmes et les
commerces alimentaires travaille
énormément
aficionado fêtards tous affluent autour
des arènes le coeur des férias dans ses
murs romain de 13 mille places visité
chaque année par près de cinq cent mille
personnes se joue corrida nos vies yade
et course camarguaise une tradition
séculaire le taureau originaire de
camargue est orné d'attributs placés sur
les cornes ou sur son front chaque
trophée à un prix que se disputent les
raseteurs des gloires locales qui
peuvent accumuler des centaines d'euros
sur une compétition
et lorsque les spectateurs quittent les
gradins il se déverse sur le boulevard
victor hugo
l'épicentre de la feria où les cas si tu
as ces bars des restaurants éphémères
sont déjà bondés
hubert est propriétaire de la brasserie
face aux arènes en fonction de leurs
sescoi la journée des enfants et leurs
parents qui se promènent qui ont pas
forcément encore et là il ya une grosse
partie avant corps et la haye après
qu'eurent et lakiha c'est chez nous et
après ces institutionnels
les gens doivent bouger parce qu ils
vont pas rester là toute la soirée ici
sénart naturel donc nous on a on appelle
tsunami local ça veut dire que la vague
quand elle descend des arènes quand vous
avez quinze mille personnes qui sortent
des arènes nous on prend au premier tour
et puis après ça remonte
ça fait comme un petit clapotis sur
monture montrent bien entendu plus les
arènes sont remplies plus le clapotis
wallon dans la bible et inversement
moi ce qui m'a surpris la preuve je suis
ici c'est que la ville s'arrête
les gens s'amusent on n'a pas d'opinion
politique on n'a pas d'opinion
religieuse
on a pas de clivage d'âge plus jeune du
lieu et tout le monde s'amuse et ses
textes incroyable le succès de ces fêtes
la das ont bien fait c'est super
dans les rues des familles avec enfants
des seniors des ados la feria rassemble
tous les âges
les touristes viennent des quatre coins
de la france
souvent en groupe
on aime l'ambiance en moyenne la façon
on aime courir les vachettes nîmes déjà
c'est le coeur c'est les copains
et puis ici c'est une vraie feria
sévillanes
on entend le flamenco l'espagne les
corridas c1 à voix basse et bayonne ou
pas d'y installer travail
gb le tour du monde
en ce week-end de pentecôte l'affluence
est au beau fixe
alors rien ne doit gâcher la fête toute
la journée et toute la nuit
l'alcool coule à flot le risque
d'incident est maximale il faut garantir
la sécurité des fêtards à l'hôtel de
police le préfet et son directeur de
cabinet prennent connaissance du
dispositif
le tandem nommé il y a quelques mois vit
sa première feria
voilà les équipes des policiers
espagnols de saint jacques de
compostelle et deux mâles ried bleu
toute l'équipe est là donc voilà chaque
année on a nos policiers espagnols et
n'est toujours à vie se passe très très
bien et n'ont fait aussi la réciproque
avec des derniers les fonctionnaires
nous qui sont aussi en espagne pour des
petites périodes comme ça et c'est très
agréable
depuis l'interdiction des corridas en
catalogne beaucoup de touristes viennent
d'espagne alors les renforts de la
guardia civil sont les bienvenus c'est
la bodega de
ici une demi douzaine de policiers
scrutent 24 heures sur 24 les images des
250 caméras de surveillance installées
par la municipalité au centre ville le
premier temps vous avez le deuxième
temps qui va à peu près jusqu'à 1h30 du
matin sur les terrains qui va inquiéter
pas existé qui voulaient des coussins
steve mans donc ça c'est une tente bien
mais quand j'ai entendu c'est si vous
mentez sachant qu'elle doit réussir au
pays vous avez le troisième temps qu'il
est extravagant qui prévaut j'aurais
immédiatement pour éviter celui là est
très compliqué et pour sécuriser ces
fêtes les forces de l'ordre ont déployé
les grands moyens
450 fonctionnaires sont mobilisés
au gré des rues des cas si ta direction
les bodégas des espaces privés est très
sélectif qui appartiennent souvent à des
associations nîmoises
certaines sont mythiques à l'image de
pablo romero
depuis quelques années ce club taurin
privatise une partie de sa bodega à des
entreprises
à quelques centaines de mètres
l'imperatore hôtel emblématique de nîmes
il sortait pour les réceptions c'est bon
tout le monde est arrivé au niveau des
cocktails n'y a pas eu de problèmes de
la société
ok bon 22 15
merci frédéric sanchez et directeur
commercial de l'hôtel depuis quelques
années il développe cette nouvelle
clientèle d'entreprises une des cas ci
ça que nous allons dans le jardin de
l'hôtel qui sont les sculptures
éphémères en beauté pour la feria pour
les réceptions et d'entreprises
donc là nous sommes sur un espace qui
peut accueillir jusqu'à 250 personnes
cet espace qui ce soir est pénalisé pour
un groupe de btp français qui invite 200
clients et donneurs d'ordre régionaux en
début de ferias et espace privé affiche
complet et représente 20% du chiffre
d'affaires de l'établissement durant ces
fêtes
un événement une réception privée
mariages baptêmes communions repas
d'anniversaire enterrements de vie de
garçons sont des choses qu'on peut avoir
mais une entreprise qui invite ses
clients à quatre fois plus de budget
qu'un événement privé
donc pour le retour économique de la
ville c'est un des très gros levier de
conquérir des entreprises dire coucou
vous en avez marre de
de là des voiles du golfe
de faire quelque chose autour du
football autour de du sport du sport
mécanique des grands prix de formule 1
venez faire la feria c'est différent
s'il ya plus de piquant c'est quelque
chose de vraiment de
insolite sortir de l'ordinaire pour
récompenser clients des équipes
le tout agrémenté de quelques bulles de
champagne l'objectif est clair faire du
business
la majorité de nos grands partenaires
nationaux sont présents ici ce soir
partager un moment de convivialité tout
en renforçant nos liens de partenariat
dans un environnement qui est on ne peut
plus agréable
un moment suspendu loin du quotidien qui
va s'étirer jusqu'à l'aube
au petit matin ce samedi
les badauds s'agglutinent déjà aux
chorales quelques minutes à percevoir
les taureaux dans quelques heures ils
seront face au matador sur le sable des
arènes
chaque taureau est acheté autour de dix
mille euros en moyenne à une ganaderia
des élevages prestigieux majoritairement
espagnol
chaque matin avant 8 heures les
représentants des toreros et des
éleveurs se retrouvent pour le sorteo le
tirage au sort des corridas du jour
les représentants des trois tours héros
vont faire trois lots de deux taureaux
c'est à dire de façon à répartir des
lots homogènes
alors les qualités requises pour avoir
trop l'homogène c'est bien évidemment
l'origine des familles des taureaux mais
ensuite les qualités de géotechnique des
taureaux c'est-à-dire un taureau selon
l'armée qui l'a letra pire c'est-à-dire
la musculature qu'il a les trois
produits vont essayer d'équilibrer de
façon à avoir trois lots homogènes et
tout ce qui se passe aux chorales
dernier et souffre en effet sous
l'autorité municipale et je suis le
représentant donc monsieur le sénateur
maire donc je représente l'autorité
chaque jour deux corridas sont proposés
à 11 heures 30 et 18 heures chacune met
en scène trois toreros chaque torero
affrontent deux taureaux dans un rituel
immuable ses hommes tirent au sort les
lots entre deux sombreros les taureaux
désigné par numéros sont attribués aux
matadors
fenton l indiana 117 fin du sorteo les
taureaux du jour sont chargés dans un
camion direction les arènes escorté par
la police municipale
ce samedi après midi sous un soleil de
plomb les arènes sont bondées les
picadors et bancs de riz se prépare
le patch aux quadri on est vraiment dans
les décors de la tauromachie c'est là où
c'est là où viennent les toreros à
droite donc il ya la chapelle
man
le royaume uni cinq minutes avant et les
toreros il s'en remettre
aux lois divines la protection divine
heures le public est venu nombreux voir
l roulis matador espagnol de 32 ans un
des meilleurs toreros au monde
aujourd'hui ils affrontent deux taureaux
de la ganaderia de car si grange
la corrida a été importée d'espagne en
1853 à bayonne
aujourd'hui du var à la gironde 66
villes du sud de la france bénéficie
d'une autorisation
les arènes appartiennent à la
municipalité pendant les ferias la
mairie loue les lieux à l'ancien torero
simon casas contre 6% de son chiffre
d'affaires depuis 30 ans il est
l'emblématique programmateurs des
corridas nîmoise il gère également les
arènes de madrid de malaga et de séville
en espagne
l'intérêt pour la collectivité
c'est à dire que n'a pas à investir dans
la production des spectacles mais le
perçoit une redevance d'environ 350
mille euros par an ce qui lui permet de
financer les festivités de la commune à
l'occasion des férias une place de
corridas coûte cher entre 45 et 105
euros
si nîmes continue de remplir ses gradins
ailleurs l'affluence est en baisse comme
pour tous secteurs d'activité ça à voir
avec le pouvoir d'achat nous sommes en
période de crise économique
et il est vrai que il n'ya pas à nîmes
mais ailleurs on peut constater une
certaine décrue proportionnelle à la
décrue de tous les secteurs d'activité
où la consommation a baissé
par conséquence de la crise économique
crise économique mais aussi discrédit
depuis quelques années la tauromachie
est attaquée à l'assemblée et au sénat
plusieurs propositions de loi tendant à
faire interdire la corrida
au même moment une cinquantaine de
militants anticorrida manifestent face
aux arènes
on est ici pour dénoncer ce qui se passe
derrière ces murs voilà un rassemblement
de personnes assis dans les gradins qui
insiste à une à une exécution organisé
voilà et se passe en trois temps alors
dans un premier temps on pique l'animal
pour lui sectionner les muscles du cou
pour pas qu'ils puissent relever la tête
pour être moins dangereux avec les
cornes
dans un deuxième temps va lui planter
des banderilles pour lui faire évacuer
le sang du haut ont dû à la pique bon
l'animal là va perdre beaucoup d'oxygène
parce qu'il va perdre beaucoup de sang
en plus ces animaux ne sont pas faits
pour courir dans l'arène
donc il s'essouffle très rapidement ils
savent fixie et en plus de ça après bon
après les banderilles on leur fait faire
quelques passes de cape et on leur
planque l'épée bon souvent à plusieurs
reprises parce qu'on a souvent du mal à
le tuer quand la tête quand ça touche
les poumons s'est il divo mis son sens
et puis des fois la mort est très très
longue quoi on ils peuvent bien se
contenter de la feria on peut très bien
se passer de la corrida sur toutes les
les corréler les gradins ne se
remplissent plus comme avant est bon il
ya quand même une avancée de ce côté là
et la feria n'a pas besoin de la corrida
contrairement à ce qu'on pense quoi
c'est plutôt la corrida qui a besoin de
la feria pour vivre voilà dans l'arène
jean paul fournier le maire contemple
elle roule y combattre son deuxième
taureau ce jour-là il coupera trois
oreilles trois trophées et une ovation
du public
siret corrida jeudi autour d'une feria
pas de corrida est à mon avis à +27 quoi
bon parce que on peut tu l'ouvrés des
bodégas peut toujours faire courir des
taureaux en cours ce livre puisque pour
se dire on ne tue pas le corrompt le
ballon revient dans le magnifique mais
je pense que ça sera pas pareil donc
j'espère qu'on n'y arrivera pas
à l'autre bout de la ville c'est l'heure
de la brigade autres traditions de la
région
l'idée est simple les attrapaïres les
attrapeurs en provençal doivent stopper
un taureau en pleine course
c'est une tradition est en fête
le but c'est de montrer aux gens que le
taureau en quoi ça consiste
c'est tout simplement une tradition si
on respecte pas le toronto pas se
respecter soi-même c'est un animal on
n'a pas lui faire de mal même même de
ceux qui nous parlent de la corrida ça
fait peut-être partie des traditions
camarguaises
mais on a aussi du respect pour ça voilà
le métro des toros y voyez-vous c'est
reparti
la nuit tombe samedi soir c'est le
record d'affluence les bars etc à sita
font le plein depuis quelques années des
adolescents de plus en plus jeunes
s'adonnent au pin jean king en français
biture express ils boivent très vite des
quantités d'alcool qu'il mixe dans des
bouteilles en plastique
le service jeunesse de la mairie tente
de faire de la prévention
bonjour les jeunes gens dérangés je
m'appelle daniel frei pour la mer et
demi mais dont la laine de première
chose à savoir si l'un de vous de vos
amis même s'ils ont croisé cabba qui se
sent vraiment pas bien
n'hésitez pas à la mener jusqu'au stand
nous on a de l'eau est en libre service
on a des jus de fruits on a un autre
stand juste au niveau des arènes de
nîmes de l'autre côté
voyez là où il ya la parole le drapeau
est passée voilà exactement mais bon ce
sera vous bon courage fait attention
toute la soirée une quinzaine d'agents
vont au devant des fêtards pour leur
distribuer documentation éthylotests
préservatifs
depuis une dizaine d'années corinne et
ses collègues sont sur le pont jusque
tard dans la nuit
bodega sans alcool ronde ou stand de
prévention une goutte d'eau face aux
conduites à risques
tu va souffler pour ce quand même voir
un petit peu respectueux abus c'est
réellement un problème chez les jeunes
et les très jeunes chez les mineurs font
mouche voilà ils ne sont pas réellement
conscients du problème parce qu'ils
viennent avec des bouteilles c'est leur
première fête et c'est vrai qu'ils ont
aimé fêter encore sans alcool ils vont
pas s'amuser
voilà très bien on va regarder c'est ce
qui est des navettes pour repartir et
ses implants nous optons de contrer tout
0077 et 0,14 dans le sens je prends
l'argent ce nom mais c'est tant mieux
pour toi
voilà là il faut que de toute manière tu
gères l'alcoolique tu fasses un canon
attention tu sais qu'on est là jusqu'à
3h30 du matin
aujourd'hui ce que je ressens après
quelques années de travail qui seront
conscients totalement des risques et qui
sont avec nous en tout cas très correct
de même
même à la limite reconnaissant de
l'espace et ça c'est ce qu'il ya de
vraiment au moins en tout cas au niveau
travail au niveau retour pour la ville
c'est ce qu'il ya de bien c'est qu'ils
reconnaissent réellement qui a des
soucis avec l'alcool
avec tout ce qui peut se passer après la
feria la nuit est déjà bien avancé les
familles et les plus âgés ont quitté la
rue vient le temps des excès
mais ça mignon
entre les barres ce sont les secouristes
de la croix rouge qui viennent en aide
aux naufragés jour 250 bénévoles sont
venus de la france entière pour assurer
ces cinq jours de feria le plus gros
événements couverts par la croix rouge
seize ambulances gère les transfèrements
décalé plus grave au centre hospitalier
de la blessure au couteau au traumatisme
suite à une chute ou une bagarre mais le
plus souvent les interventions sont liés
à l'alcool
pensez bien bien bien remarqué à quelle
heure il partait où ils vont retour à
domicile et 3 heures du matin c'est le
pic d'activité pour viviane et ses
équipes beaucoup d'alcool ise mais de
plus en plus de bagarres
la l'alcool les gens le plus en plus
c'est un col mauvais donc sa part assez
vite remarque de patience
et c'est nerveux pour rien donc c'est
beaucoup beaucoup de bagger depuis
depuis deux trois ans
chez toi sur le côté gauche assure le
côté viviane by sa onzième feria et
depuis quelques années le nombre de
mineurs prise en charge compliquer sa
mission c'est soit par an soit police il
n'y a pas de choix soit par an soit
police et une autorité légale en prend
en charge et 13 13 14 ans qui sont en
ville sans leurs parents
donc ça ça devient problématique pour
nous parce que
sur une fête comme ça et même sur tous
les dispositifs les mineurs ne peuvent
pas repartir sans autorité légale
donc on appelle les parents à l'heure où
les prend en charge à 4 heures du matin
général s'est fait pas trop plaisir donc
le mineur ne repart jamais seul dans un
dispositif comme ça c'est trop dangereux
pour lui ce bon j'ai une haute
responsabilité
ce samedi soir les bénévoles viendront
en aide à plus de 200 personnes
ce dimanche après-midi la ville se
réveille il fait déjà 35 degrés c'est la
journée la plus chaude de la semaine
certains n'ont pas dormi d'autres
courent déjà derrière les taureaux
sous les tilleuls de l'imperatore la
terrasse et les jardins sont bondés hier
des milliers de personnes sont passées
ici faire la fête
la nuit a été courte pour frédéric au
menu de son après-midi relations
publiques
même succès à 6h30 et j'avais des
clients invités ce matin à la corrida
donc le révéla 10h30 a été un peu un peu
musclée en terrasse personnalités
politiques notables locaux
nîmes comme cannes roland garros a lieu
où l'on vient pour être vu et qui
entretient le prestige de l'imperatore
et pour accueillir ces personnalités est
géré l'afflux de clientèle l'hôtel a
recruté en langage 140 personnes en
extra c'est à dire que moi de variants
ont fait 181 bulletins de salaire au
lieu d'une quarantaine habituellement on
ne peut plus réduire la feria aux
corridas mais c'est quand même le motif
devenu de beaucoup beaucoup de monde
étrange et espagnoles d'amérique du sud
même de français qui viennent d'autres
régions c'est un motif de venus
développer la clientèle d'aficionadas
international un levier pour la ville
car l'amateur de corrida et épicurien et
dépensier panier moyen
1500 euros par personne la fête continue
autour des arènes les forces de l'ordre
sont présentes en nombre
alors quand le soleil se couche les
rondes s'intensifie
objectif de ces patrouilles être visible
marquer le territoire
mieux ce soir cette histoire me no grave
voilà c'est sécurisé air frais personnes
à les prévenir toutes les modalités
cette nuit ils sont 250 à être mobilisés
vous avez les crs vous avez jana mobile
vous avez les policiers nationaux et la
sécurité publique nous voilà comme on
est là on a même les collègues la police
municipale
le dispositif est particulièrement
musclé au tour de la maison carrée c'est
ici que la plupart des incidents ont
lieu au dojo d'intervention bon les gars
n'ont pas cours
tout cela dans la nuit avant que la
prévention explique aux jeunes et voilà
les couteaux ne veut pas bon là il avait
2 4 de dr de cannabis pour ce soir on
peut pas traiter ce sens n'est pas là
pour ça et comme ça ils se passent le
mot et des couteaux des vols à l'arraché
ont été signalés à quelques mètres la
patrouille ce poste donc au milieu des
fêtards où elle restera une partie de la
nuit opération dissuasion
à la sortie de la ville au même moment
150 gendarmes bloquent les principaux
carrefours
l'embouteillage et monstres tous les
conducteurs sont contrôlés en soirée se
nomme merci bonsoir messieurs dames
contre gendarmerie contre l'alcoolémie
en soumettre à un dépistage
un phénomène que l'on constate notamment
depuis l'année dernière c'est une
proportion de plus en plus importante de
femmes alcoolisé ce qui n'était pas le
cas avant souvent les femmes prenez le
volant à la place du copain ou du mari
qui avait fait la fête
elle continue à le faire mais
malheureusement elles doivent également
donc on a un nombre de femmes
verbalisées qui a tendance à augmenter
la proportion est plus importante
qu'elle ne l'était il ya quelques années
on est maintenant quasiment à une
normalisation sur deux qui concerne une
femme ce qui n'est pas du tout le cas
même le directeur de cabinet du préfet
est mise à contribution les retraites
permis sont immédiats des savoirs
demande d'être présent pour montrer la
visibilité aussi la présence aux côtés
des gendarmes mais sur ce cas très
précis
la présence d'un membre du corps
préfectoral permet de suspendre
immédiatement le permis
des dizaines de véhicules resteront
immobilisé en attendant le dégrisement
de leurs propriétaires sur l'ensemble de
la feria puis de 6000 contrôles seront
effectués à la clé près de 400 pv mais
aucun accident mortel
quatre heures les bodégas ferment une à
une démarre alors le ballet des laveuses
les 130 agents ont quatre heures pour
faire place nette
près de 330 tonnes de déchets seront
collectés sur ces quelques jours
principalement des verres en plastique
alors pour réduire l'empreinte
écologique
la mairie veut promouvoir un gobelet
consigné dès l'année prochaine
à ces occasions là c'est vraiment le
seul moment de l'année où on voit notre
travail où les gens nous félicitent de
notre arrêt dans tous les agents sont
vraiment très valorisé durant ce
week-end et ils attendent ça voilà comme
un événement aussi pour eux pour leur
travail et
voilà c'est vraiment important pour la
ville est propre les rues sont rendues à
la circulation et aux badauds
c'est le dernier jour lundi de pentecôte
l'heure du bilan pour jérémy du début à
la fin ça commence elle à été vous
énormément de monde les gens contents
heureux un beau temps tout est au beau
fixe
c'est du stress parce qu'on a toujours
envie de bien faire et de bien gérer de
faire revenir les jambes parce que
malraux qui aime même s'il ya du
tourisme c'est une clientèle qui revient
à chaque feria clients qui reviennent
ici chaque année deux fois par an le 10
septembre 2000 donc on a eu forcément
d'augmenter cette clientèle donc
beaucoup de stress parce qu'on a
toujours envie de mieux faire une bonne
carrière à tout le monde est content
tout le monde se souvient savoir que
l'esprit l'équipe l'ambiance la qualité
et savait que bon ben je pense qu on est
sorti victorieux encore une fois sur
cinq jours près d'un million de
personnes ont profité de la feria un
succès néanmoins fragile en temps de
crise économique
écrasée de soleil balayé par le mistral
nîmes la romaine tente une opération
séduction à tirer encore attirer plus
les touristes les entreprises au delà de
la haute saison
pendant ces hivers toujours trop calme
alors la ville attend impatiemment son
classement au patrimoine de l'unesco
la romanité un sésame qui lui assurerait
un public supplémentaire à l'heure où
les menaces planent sur la corrida
une aubaine
il
il est monstrueux
m
sanaa
ceux-là
sauven
dès ce matin
ce mec là